I study proteins and proteins have been
thought to have one structure that has
one function or fold I'm sending this
group of proteins called fold switching
proteins so they can actually change
their structures and their functions in
response to changes in the cell so you
can kind of imagine fold switching
proteins are like a transformer where in
one case the protein is like a robot
that does one thing and then in another
case in response to changes in our
bodies it becomes a car and can do
something else and an advantage to this
is it can respond really quickly to
changes in our bodies back in high
school I did not imagine myself being a
scientist at all before going to college
I did kind of fall in love with math
like when I took calculus I was like wow
this is so cool it was like the first
time I realized that math could be
useful for something beyond balancing my
checkbook at the end of my sophomore
year of college my dad was diagnosed
with stage 4 lymphoma he went through
multiple rounds of chemo and it was just
a really hard process just watching that
happen and and let thinking I wonder if
there's a better way some of the
proteins that I'm working on that
actually do this phenomenon called fold
switching are actually associated with
diseases so cancer Alzheimer's
autoimmune disease bacterial and viral
infections if by the end of my life even
successful treatment was made based on
this that would be amazing
NLM has a really strong track record in
computation there are a lot of excellent
scientists here and so I thought it
would be great to be able to work with
them I'm also like really grateful to
have the freedom to pursue what I want
to do and I'm really like happy to be
here and be able to like take chances
that I probably couldn't do in most
other environments